welcome back everybody to the david
pakman show my name is luke beasley i'm
going to be filling in for david today
while he is away on paternity leave
obviously exciting stuff going on huge
congratulations to david and his family
we have a massive show to get into so
let's dive right in
last night the january 6th committee
held their first big public hearing
where they started the process of going
through all the information they have
gathered over the last number of months
and i thought that the chairman
congressman thompson as well as liz
cheney who kind of led the presentation
for the night did a really good job of
outlining a few main points so we're
going to do a bird's eye view
look at these main points and then we're
going to dive into some specific moments
the first is donald trump was absolutely
supportive and they made this very clear
of the writers he was watching it unfold
and he was supportive of it and as we're
going to get into in just a second he
was even
cheering on
supportive of
the rioters who wanted to kill his own
vice president
the second big thing was he absolutely
was told by people close to him
repeatedly that the claims he was making
were false
i think we had all kind of assumed that
but that was shown as well people like
former attorney general william barr and
his own daughter ivanka trump were aware
that the election was not stolen there's
no evidence for that and yet trump kept
perpetuating it
the third big thing was there was a
clear and
planned coordinated effort
to attack the capital by the proud boys
and the oath keepers and the reason why
i say that is because there was some
question of was it just a protest that
got out of hand or was it a premeditated
event by some people and at least in the
case of the proud boys and the oath
keepers it was premeditated and that's a
big deal the fourth big thing and this
is the most important part of all of
this is
donald trump was the first u.s president
in all of our history
to not respect the peaceful transition
of power and that is huge because that
is absolutely necessary to holding
together our democracy and he just spit
all over it
because he was just upset he lost an
election
he stomped on our entire history of
doing a really good job
the person who's in power if they lose
they respectfully exit and do what they
can to make it a peaceful transition and
so
that put our democracy in peril and
that's a huge point we have to keep
stating so that everyone does not forget
it
obviously these videos can't be super
super long so i can't go through
everything that i would want to
from this hearing because there was a
lot jam packed into it the stuff that i
can't cover i'll try to get to some of
it on my own show so you can find that
at luke beasley on youtube if you're
watching this on youtube or listening to
the podcast it'll be in the description
box a link to my channel but definitely
check out
my show luke beasley on youtube but i
also encourage you to watch the whole
hearing if you haven't already yourself
because there is tons of stuff
that are super super important for you
to be aware of they came out of that
hearing
so the first
humongous
bombshell
that came out of this hearing
was
it was exposed that donald trump was
supportive
of the rioters who were
chanting hang mike pence he was made
aware that that was happening
and he was supportive of it
let's take a look
and aware of the rioters chance to hang
mike pence the president responded with
this sentiment quote
maybe our supporters have the right idea
mike pence quote deserves it i know
because there's already been coverage of
a lot of this and you've probably
already run it through in your head you
can get a little numbed out to it but
really think about this the president of
the united states was supportive
of a mob of people who wanted to murder
his vice president you would watch that
a movie like that's not even something
that would be fiction right if you ever
heard that type of story it's a
fictional
no the president of the united states
wanted his vice president to get
murdered that's what we just watched and
we can't forget that these crazy things
happened or get numbed out to them
the next big thing i want to look at is
william barr
trump's attorney general
testified in a pre-recorded interview
about how
he looked into it saw there was no fraud
that would have made any difference in
the election no wide scale
widespread fraud and then we'll play the
clip of ivanka who got asked about
barr's statement and pretty much said
yeah i mean
if barr said it like i believe it so
pretty much i don't
agree with my dad's statements let's
take a look i told the president no
uncertain terms
that
i did not see evidence of fraud
and you know that would have affected
the outcome
of the election and frankly a year and a
half later i haven't seen anything to to
change my mind on that
how did that affect your perspective
about the election when attorney general
barr made that statement
it affected my perspective i respect
attorney general barr
um
so i
accepted what he said was saying
so donald trump's attorney general and
his daughter are both well aware
and
william barr told trump that trump's
claims were false and yet he kept on
going with them and
the amount of damage that that did if he
had stopped at some point before january
6th and realize you know what i thought
it was stolen but looks like all the
evidence has come out it wasn't actually
stolen we would have saved so
much damage from being done to our
democracy the next big thing that
happened in the hearing was a
documentarian testified under oath
and
again i encourage you guys to go watch
this hearing for yourself but i'll give
you a quick summary so the documentarian
had been allowed access
in the days leading up to january 6th
and on january 6th to follow around
enrique tario who is the leader of the
proud boys and
throughout that i guess they wanted him
or were okay with him making a
documentary about the organization or
whatever was going on
and what he captured and witnessed
throughout that process proved what i
mentioned earlier that the proud boys
in coordination with the oath keepers
had actually
planned the events of that day and we're
just executing a plan to attack the
capital we'll look at some clips from
that testimony that came out on january
5th the night before the attack
you were with the head of the proud boys
mr tario in washington d.c
what happened uh we picked up his bags
and went to get some other bags from the
phoenix hotel where we
um
encountered mr stewart roads uh from the
oath keepers
we drove down into the parking garage
and filmed the scene of mr tario and mr
rhodes
and certain other individuals
in that garage the committee learned
that the oath keepers set up quick
reaction forces outside of the city in
virginia where they stored arms the goal
of these quick reaction forces was to be
on standby just in case president trump
invoked the insurrection act did vote
keepers ever provide weapons to members
i'm gonna decline to answer that and put
them in grounds they're acting as if
they're executing some military
operation
so after the documentarian spoke a
female police officer
recounted her experience trying
desperately to defend the capital and
one of the stories she tells she's
holding one of those bike racks that
doubles as a fence and she gets shoved
backwards hits her head on a railing and
then onto the cement and gets knocked
out cold
so she goes through and walks through
that and then walks through the other
traumatizing horrible things that
happened
and that she witnessed that day that
kind of brings me to my last big point
on this
my baseline emotion watching all of this
was just rage
at the beginning i thought about this a
lot before but at the beginning because
they pointed out it was top of mind for
me that we have this long history of
peaceful transitions of power
and while
you and i both know some horrible things
have happened in american history we've
failed miserably in the past many times
but the one thing we got right
was that peaceful transition to power
and it's what kept our democracy alive
and donald trump
was willing to let that all
uh die to let democracy in america die
for his own gain for his own benefit
because he wanted more to believe he won
and to stay in power than just admitting
he lost the election and and moving
along like every other president had
done in the past
that's a fact we cannot let people lose
sight of
that's how deeply selfish and
narcissistic he is he doesn't care about
the greater good of the country because
if he did he would have
realized the claims he was making were
false
and then conceded
and helped to make a trend a peaceful
transition to power but that's not what
he did
i'll be giving more my thoughts on this
on my show again you can find that at
luke beasley on youtube
uh b-e-a-s-l-e-y is how you spell my
last name um or if you're watching this
on youtube or listening to the podcast
it will be in the description box a
little link you can click to check me
out
so we just discussed the january 6
hearings where some bombshell new
information were revealed or was
revealed
trump being supportive of the rioters
who wanted to kill mike pence they
wanted to hang mike pence and trump
supported that
clear evidence showing that trump was
being repeatedly told by people around
him
uh that his election claims were false
and much more so even before these
hearings just the fact that they were
happening enraged trump but then of
course afterwards he was not too happy
and before we take a look at what he
said the scary part about all this
is if you watch the hearings it would it
was made so clear something we already
knew but it was made really clear in
these hearings
that
all of this was motivated by trump
and the people perpetuating his same
lies
people said after the fact who were
arrested the ones who had
broken into the capital
i did this because president trump told
me to
let's take a quick look at that it made
me want to come was the fact that
you know i had supported trump all that
time
uh i did believe you know that the
election was being stolen
um and trump asked us to come he
personally asked for us to come to dc
that day
and i thought
for everything he's done for us
that this is the only thing he's going
to ask me
and then people are reading his tweets
while they're breaking into the capitol
my kids didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution giving
states a chance to certify a corrected
set of facts
not the fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked to previously
certify the u.s demands the truth so all
of this was caused by him telling these
lies and as was revealed
he was told by people close to him that
what he was saying was not true that
there was no evidence for the claims he
was making but yet he kept going out and
lying
still
and
the craziest part too is that we're a
year and a half later
still no evidence of the claims he's
made and yet he's still going off about
the election being stolen
and before the hearings happened as well
as after the hearings happen with all
these revelations that came out his only
response to all of it is to keep telling
those lies
he took the truth social saying
and this is before the hearings the
unselect committee didn't spend one
minute studying the reason that people
went to washington dc in massive numbers
far greater than the fake news media is
willing to report
he's so obsessed with that or that the
unselects are willing to even mention
because january 6 was not simply a
protest it represented the greatest
movement in the history of our country
to make america great again it was about
an election that was rigged and stolen
random capitalizations for no reason and
a country that was about to go to hell
and look at our country now and he puts
out another truth saying the unselect
committee of political thugs essentially
the same group brought you the fully
debunked
and discredited russia russia russia
hoax and many others refuse to study and
report and aniani goes to make the exact
same point and then we'll skip to after
the hearings happened
so the unselect committee of political
hacks refused to play
any of the many positive witnesses and
statements
refuses to talk of the election fraud
and irregularities that took place on a
massive scale and decided to use a
documentary maker from fake news abc to
spin only negative footage our country
is in such trouble well i could not
agree with that last statement more our
country is in a lot of trouble but for
the opposite reasons than he would think
so
what he's doing is so scary because
we're a year and a half out
and
watching everything that has happened
all the damage that's been caused by his
lies
his only response to all of that is to
keep telling his lies so what he's doing
is setting up a situation where the
exact same thing
could happen again
this is a massive threat to our
democracy
and
while i totally
recognize the democrats have so many
issues
and we should point those out criticize
them
what they will do and what we know that
biden would do if he lost the next
election is concede and give up power
and that is what holds our democracy
together and so while i know a lot of
people on the right think this statement
comes off as hyperbolic
it's true donald trump is the biggest
threat right now
to american democracy again i know a lot
of right-wingers hear that they're like
oh my god some lefty but really think
about it in 2020 he was okay allowing
uh our democratic process to fail for
his own gain so that he could stay in
power all based off of lies
he was willing to let all that happen
just for his own gain
how is that not the biggest threat if
he's clearly trying to set up a
situation where he can do it again he's
telling the same lies
and so
we can't withstand another january 6th
we can't withstand having a president in
power who refuses
uh or does everything possible to the
last second to keep himself in power
even if he lost the election we just
cannot
survive that as a democracy
and so
if you're on the right and you're
reasonable at all i beg you to think
about with all the issues you probably
have with the left
on this
take a stand for
democracy and the importance of having
people in power who respect our
democracy enough to want to give up
power if they lose a fair and free
election
it doesn't matter we can figure out our
disagreements later but as of now we
should unite conservatives and liberals
and i mean the reasonable conservatives
who don't believe the election lies to
do everything we can to prevent trump
from getting in power so that we don't
have to go through that again
where maybe it goes worse next time
because i can tell you
everything that went wrong for trump in
2020 that caused biden to eventually get
in power he's gonna be ready
and not allow those things to go wrong
again so we do have to take it seriously
and everyone who is even somewhat
reasonable needs to unite to prevent him
from getting back in power
super appreciative to the david pakman
show for having me fill in today don't
forget to check out my channel luke
beasley on youtube if you're watching on
youtube or listening to the podcast
there will be a link in the description
box definitely go check me out we'll be
right back with much more
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show
this is luke beasley filling in for
david today while he's away on paternity
leave if you like what you're seeing
definitely go check me out on youtube i
have my own show it's called the louis
beasley show
but you can just search luke beasley on
youtube and you will find it
lots of good stuff going down there so
before we get into this next story i
just want to warn you it's absolutely
horrifying and heartbreaking an 11 year
old girl who survived the evol day
shooting
spoke to congress testified in front of
congress
about how she watched her teacher she
watched her friend get killed by the
gunman
who went into that school in uvalde rob
elementary and one of the stories you
may have heard that's just absolutely
horrifying
is
she was afraid after the gunman had gone
through shot her friend shot her teacher
that he was going to come back around
and shoot her and so to make it look
like she had already been shot
she put her hand in the blood of her
friend
and smeared it all over her so that she
would look like she was also all
bloodied up and and had been hit
let's watch a few moments from this
testimony and then we'll discuss
there's a door between our classroom the
window
and then he went to the other classroom
and then he went
there's a door between our classrooms
and he went to there and
saw my teacher and told my teacher
tonight and shot her in the head
and then he shot
some of my classmates
and the whiteboard
when i went to the backpacks uh
he shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was gonna come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and
i put it all over me
and
what did you do then when you put the
blood on yourself
just stay quiet and then i got my
teacher's phone
and called him away
what are you telling anyone now i told
her that we need help
and
to send the police
in the
classroom right
or things that you want different what
would it be
to have security
for you
do you feel safe at school
why not
because i don't want it to happen again
do you think it's gonna happen again
the entire story is i mean there's words
heartbreaking but you can't describe
the level of
of wrong that that is no 11 year old
should have to recount an experience
like that no person obviously
but when you see it coming from an 11
year old girl
it's just incomprehensible
no kid should go to school afraid that
they might get shot
that's not something in a civilized
developed country that should happen
i know you've all seen these numbers
before but i'm gonna throw up a graphic
of the united states gun violence
compared to other countries we stand way
apart something's wrong
and
we hear all the time from anti-gun
reform advocates
there's all these other things oh it's
mental health it's violent video games
it's the security of the schools and
while i want to address those two
let's look into how we can make schools
safe
and secure let's look into mental health
issues in the country of course i want
to discuss that but we can't ignore
the massive
obvious
in our face issue which is
gun laws
other countries have all of these other
areas that they also have issues with
mental health is a great example of that
lots of other countries are dealing with
mental health problems
but their gun violence is nothing
compared to the united states and that
is because we don't
regulate guns in a common sense way
we're not talking about taking away your
second amendment nothing we're talking
about doing very common sense
regulations and laws that will protect
lives undeniably
now
a lot of times when we discuss this
people will say
i hear
liberals say common sense a lot what do
they mean by that so let's just go
through four big main easy
very popular among the country type
policies that we could implement
universal background checks
red flag laws
raising the age to purchase these
weapons
and waiting periods and that would in
many of the past cases we've saw i've
seen make a difference and it would
prevent future things from happening
uh
going forward
it just doesn't make what any sense why
everyone want to be on board with this
and polling shows
actual americans are on board with this
but then for some reason republican
politicians
specifically are standing in the way of
doing anything
and
i've heard a lot of people witness after
witnessing
these horrible tragedies and then the
inaction by the people in power
i've heard people express the sentiment
of there's no hope it's impossible
i kind of give up
we see time and time again horrible
things happen that you would think would
wake every single
person in power up but it doesn't
and i just want to say while i totally
empathize with that it is
enraging
watching those people who are supposed
to solve issues like this in our country
not do it
and and you do have those moments where
like if it hasn't
happened in the past with all the
tragedies we've seen why is something
going to change now
but i do think
11 year old girls like the one we just
watched
and
all of the young people we've seen all
of the other
innocent lives that have been lost in
mass shootings they all deserve
us to not give up
they at least deserve that from us
we can't single-handedly make this
happen but the one thing we can
dedicate to each one of those lost lives
and each one of the
people like the one we just watched who
are forever traumatized by an event like
this
is to not give up we can at least give
that to them and so while it's gonna
look impossible
many days
i beg each one of you because this is
what
causes change to happen to not give up
to keep pushing everything you can
possibly do to keep
this issue
on the front of mind of the politicians
and of americans broadly we previously
discussed the 11 year old girl in uvalde
texas who
testified to congress about her
experiences watching her friend and her
teacher get killed and one of the things
that i
i think when i watch something like that
is surely everyone's overcome with
emotion and thinks we have to act we
have to implement at least some common
sense gun reform we can talk also about
mental health and all those things but
step one common sense gun reform
universal background checks red flag
laws waiting periods
um raising the age
for when you can get guns right
well as you all know
that's not the way that everyone
responds to these tragedies
unfortunately unfortunately a lot of
people
republican politicians specifically see
their whole job
when a tragedy like this happens as
standing in the way of anything from
being done
at least on the issue of guns nothing
can happen
in regard to gun control after these
tragedies and that's what they see their
job as
and
they kind of offer up vague solutions as
i kind of allude to earlier oh it's
mental health oh it's school security
but
they don't propose specific solutions
and then their primary focus is
distracting from the big blinking red
led sign which is gun control
and louis gomer did this exactly on the
house floor recently
saying that
guys
saying that the reason maybe the reason
that mass shootings have gone up is
because kids don't pray in school
anymore
we were told in debate last week don't
want to hear any more about social media
violent video games hollywood mental
illness and they sure don't want to hear
any more about prayers they're disgusted
hearing about prayers don't want to hear
any more about fatherlessness drug use
look maybe if we heard more prayers from
leaders of this country instead of
taking god's name in vain
we wouldn't have the mass killings like
we didn't have before
prayer was eliminated from school
what do you say to that i know this is
such a cliche thing but
louie how do you sleep with yourself
honestly i know that someone like louis
gomer is completely aware that
implementing commonsense gun reform that
would not be infringing on anyone's
second amendment right
would save lives it would save countless
lives
but for some reason whether it's
appealing to a radical part of his base
keeping those nra funds flowing i don't
know what his reason is but for some
reason
he would rather stand in the way of
doing any of that
and he would rather say oh maybe it's
because kids don't pray in school really
imagine staring in the face of all of
the evidence
that shows the reason why america stands
so much apart or set so much apart from
all these other countries and the level
of gun violence we have is because we
don't have
uh common sense gun laws imagine looking
at all that evidence and going i don't
care
i would rather
not just ignore the evidence but
actively work against
anyone from
acting in a logical manner based on that
evidence
to prevent tragedies from happening
in this country i
honestly that clip looks like someone
doing a parody of a
anti-gun reform uh republican politician
like that's not even real
oh no it's not gun it's not the lack of
gun reform or the lack of common sense
gun laws it's kids not doing their
morning prayer in class
you don't believe that no way anyone
will believe that
and i'm so down again like i'll say this
a thousand times
whenever these conversations come up
let's invest in mental health let's try
to promote happy healthy supporting
families
let's secure our schools
but then let's also
implement common sense gun reform it's
just not that hard but he makes it hard
people like him make it hard and they
try to distract
and even as ludicrous ways is saying oh
it's morning prayers that have gone away
that caused these mass shootings in
schools we're continuing our discussion
around gun violence that's been
reignited due to the recent mass
shootings in buffalo and uvalde and then
a bunch of other mass shootings just
since those two
but one of the talking points you'll
hear the most i think you've all
probably heard this whenever a tragedy
tragedy like this happens is
it's not guns that kill people it's
people that kills people and at a really
fundamental level okay that's true right
guns don't fly around and shoot people
a person has to pull the trigger and
oftentimes in every mass shooting it was
someone who's deranged and has horrible
motivations all of that
i agree to
but
what you and i understand and why we see
that
slogan or that
talking point to be so harmful
is
the person who's already deranged has
those bad motivations their ability to
kill people
and to kill a higher number of people
comes down to how effective of a killing
tool a weapon they have to do that
and so at a basic level i think everyone
understands this right if i say you
absolutely have to be attacked you have
no choice someone's going to attack you
at your home but you can decide if it's
going to be someone with just their bare
hands or someone with an ar-15 everyone
knows they would choose the person with
the bare hands
so then
you understand then if someone's
deranged and they have
psychotic ambitions to kill people
but they can't get their hands on
something that does that act killing so
well then they're not going to be able
to cause as much
suffering as many deaths as much carnage
so then without changing the hearts and
minds of these people which we should
also try to do of course
but without having to get into that real
complex topic how do you prevent someone
from becoming so deranged
you are
eliminating the amount of damage they
can do
so
a great example of this is something
that happened in california a few days
ago this happened at a hospital radio
call went out reporting a person armed
with a knife at the hospital officers
determined that someone had stabbed
three hospital employees swat officers
entered the hospital around 5 25 pm the
fbi was at the scene and offering
assistance where needed
lapd chief michael moore said around 5
30 that officers had cornered the
suspect alone in the area of the
emergency room at the encino hospital
we've locked it down we've isolated the
individual he said so a man goes into a
hospital
trying to kill people he stabs three
people uh fbi corners him
outcome no one dies
in tulsa if you remember a man went into
a medical facility so these stories are
very similar two men go into medical
facilities trying to kill people one of
them has a knife one of them has a gun
the one with the gun
kills three people the one with the
knife stabs three people and no one dies
so you can see the point that i'm
getting to while of course it is the
fault of the individuals it is the fault
of those two men for trying to kill
people all the blame is on them
their ability to actually enact the
violence and the suffering and the death
that they were trying to
did come down to the type of weapon they
had and so if we can prevent certain
people like those two guys from getting
or at least the one who did get the gun
from getting such effective
killing tools weapons that are designed
to kill as many people as possible
possible we're gonna save lives
and we can do that and why anyone
standing in the way of that honestly
while i can tell you the reasons i don't
understand them like i don't understand
how
appealing to a radical base or appealing
to nra would possibly come above
in your mind in your heart
protecting innocent people
from getting killed in cold blood i
one of the biggest things i'm confused
about is watching the way that certain
republican politicians are acting about
this issue it's disturbing but this
example shows while yes people kill
people
people's ability
to kill a lot of people will come down
to if they can get their hands on a
on something that's designed to do that
or not
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at
david patreon.com show things are really
heating up for people around donald
trump we saw some bombshells in the
january 6 hearings but additionally his
former advisor and someone who spread
the big lie a lot peter navarro was
recently arrested and is having to beg
magga
for money to fight his legal battles
what a fallen star
reading from business insider former
trump advisor peter navarro said he was
put in handcuffs and leg irons while
being arrested after trying to board a
flight at the airport in nashville on
friday navarro was indicted on charges
of contempt of congress on friday after
repeatedly defying the orders of the
house committee investigating the
january 6 riot per unsealed court
documents
so he didn't comply with a january 6
committee subpoena
and because of that he got arrested and
after that arrest the desperate
complaining immediately began with him
calling the fbi agents who arrested him
nazis okay
and saying he was treated like he was
not he was in al-qaeda of course the
justice department is disputing his
characterization of those events but now
as greater men such as rudy giuliani
have had to do after being left in
donald trump's dust
he's now asking for money for magga to
fight his legal battles let's take a
look it's just i mean
this is so wrong seven this book taking
back trump's america help me please i'm
looking at a half a million dollars in
legal expenses according to some legal
experts or more this could go to a
million i've got to raise that money i
i can't kill my retirement by by
defending this this these baseless
charges taking back trump samaria please
go to amazon right now order that book
the book
yikes happy i'm not you peter um i will
say in all seriousness we should not
take pleasure in just because we don't
like someone watching them crash and
burn that's just not cool
no i'm kidding um that was awesome so
in a world that's so tough it's nice to
see people who tried to assault our
democracy and spread lies about a free
and fair election get a little bit of
punishment okay that's pretty nice
uh like i said he refused to comply with
a january 6 committee subpoena
and it's a good sign that the justice
department is finally getting a little
bit more justifiably aggressive
in their enforcement and hopefully we'll
see that trend continue
of course only with crimes that have
actually been committed not for
political reasons
but uh
if you can uncover real crimes the
justice department even if it's touchy
people need to actually take appropriate
actions
i'll be following this story closely
seeing what happens with peter navarro
on my channel you can check it out luke
beasley on youtube
that's beasley if you're watching on
youtube or listening to the podcast
there will be a link in the description
you can just click to check out my
channel i encourage you to do so
we have a massive story that came out
the leading candidate in the gop primary
for governor
in michigan ryan kelly was arrested
arrested for his involvement in the
january 6 riots
that's
this is insane
ryan kelly a republican running for
governor in michigan who's at the
capitol during the january 6 attack was
arrested as home in allendale michigan
on thursday morning according to mara
schneider a special agent with the fbi
mr kelly is the first person running for
election in a major state or federal
race to be charged in connection with
the attack according to a criminal
complaint mr kelly was charged with
committing violence against a person of
property on restricted grounds damaging
federal property disorderly conduct and
entering a restricted building or
grounds without permission all four
charges are misdemeanors according to
bill
miller
now ryan kelly is expectedly denying
these claims but this video i i can't
tell if it's him but allegedly it is him
entering the capital
waving the crowd along with him let's
look
[Music]
[Music]
he also sent out a message when he got
arrested that just said political
prisoner that was it political prisoner
which honestly i think
the right wing either never knew or
right when january 6 happened forgot
what that actually means when you say
political prisoner that has a meaning
and you're not using it correctly
because if i posed a hypothetical to you
and i said
um
an individual broke into a federal
building
vandalized it a bunch
fought with the police do you think they
should be held criminally responsible
every conservative will go yeah of
course what do you mean but then because
it's january 6 now
any enforcement of our laws makes it
makes the people who it's enforced on
political prisoners that makes no sense
like just because you did it for
political reasons
because you believe that trump's lies
doesn't make
us the ones doing something wrong and
making you a political prisoner
i don't know uh but obviously he should
have due process and
if he can prove that he wasn't there
then he shouldn't be held accountable of
course but all the available evidence we
have now
not looking too good for him and funny
enough this is making an already insane
gubernatorial primary in michigan on the
gop side
even more wild if you guys remember this
was the same primary where five
candidates were disqualified from
running because they used fraudulent
signatures
to get on the ballot
like you would think it wouldn't get any
more bizarre than in one primary five of
the candidates fraudulent fraudulently
got on a ballot
but then
the leading candidate
gets arrested for storming the united
states capital
like
american politics is unbelievable and
the scariest part of this is
this could very likely make him more
popular among the republican base in
michigan
in any sane world finding out one of the
candidates
in a race for governor tried to
violently overturn the results of a free
and fair election will get you
immediately
banished from polite society
but in the wacko world we live in this
can make him a rising star
you already know he's going to have a
successful podcast
and with that
i'm gonna do the most shameless
transition to self-promotion speaking of
podcasts you can listen to my podcast by
searching luke beasley on any platform
or go to youtube and search luke beasley
very nice we'll be back with more after
this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
a few days ago david did a story about a
man who went to an arlington city
council meeting
and said the punishment for being gay
is death or it should be death
that man came from the same church as a
pastor that we're going to look at today
in a disturbing clip that has gone viral
steadfast church is the name of the
church
and
he said
just like his i guess colleague or
someone else who went to that same
church that gay people should be killed
but this one went as far as to
specifically say how they should be shot
in the back of the head
warning this is very disturbing but
let's take a look
say is the answer is the solution for
the homosexual in 2022 here in the new
testament here in the book of romans
that they are worthy of death
these people should be put to death
every single homosexual in our country
should be charged with the crime the
abomination
of homosexuality that they have they
should be convicted in a lawful trial
they should be sentenced with death they
should be lined up against the wall and
shut in the back of the head
that's what god teaches
that's what the bible says you don't
like it you don't like god's word
because that is what god said i mean
what is there to say to that
it's disturbing it's disgusting all the
things but
the fact that he's pretending
to be expressing these views because he
feels it is the word of god is horrible
i mean
you are hateful deeply deeply hateful
you don't feel called by god to say and
do these things you have a deep hatred
in your heart
and are desperate to find an excuse to
spew it everywhere that you can in the
world
and then let's address what he's saying
seriously i don't know why
we would do that but let's do it anyways
if you don't understand that your
specific religions sets of beliefs can't
be enforced on everyone in a country you
don't understand our constitution you
don't understand how a functioning
society would work
free democratic society so even if he
genuinely believed this
was his religion this is what god was
calling him to do
there is absolutely no way
you could figure out a way to justify
enforcing your specific beliefs on
an entire country of people and wanting
to
just got a lot of rage i just almost had
like a heart palpitation um what the
heck
and kill people because of your religion
or your interpretation of your religion
and let me make something clear there
are wonderful christians there are
beautiful so many christians i'm
christian raised and
tons of people around me are amazing
christians they serve
the country they serve the people around
them
they see jesus's teachings as being
service oriented
helping people
who are disadvantaged vantage loving
people unconditionally all those things
and they're amazing
this is not all christians
and like i said before i don't even
think this is christianity i think this
man
is using christianity
to express views he already has deep
down in his heart because he is a
hateful person
for some reason the concept of anyone
being different anyone loving different
scares him
probably born on a deep deep insecurity
but then he uses
a
religious text to justify spewing his
hatred
and i'm noticing as
broader society moves forward like over
the last few generations we've moved
forward a lot on lgbtq issues
a small portion is kind of reacting to
that progress by launching way backwards
and we can't
allow this as a country we can't allow
a small minority of this country
to inflict pain
on
other groups of people just because of
their weird distorted perverted
understanding of their own religion
that's not acceptable
and i think every religious person or
non-religious person should be able to
unite around the fact regardless of our
disagreements otherwise
that this should not be allowed and this
should not be accepted in our country
he's calling for the murder
of people just because they live
differently than him and don't subscribe
to his particular set of religious
religious beliefs
as i said i was raised christians i know
tons of christians in my life and i know
all of them would be just as disgusted
as i am by watching this
and so
how about you go out if you're someone
like him and you believe what he
believes how about you actually do
something in the world that's good
i see this
and i i had someone point this out to me
and i never want to forget to point this
out tons of people who are religious
do amazing things with it that's what i
do with my religion
i do good things with it
it it motivates people to do good things
and tons of the
charity and service that we see in our
country is done by people who are
motivated by the religious beliefs so
this isn't a massive thing on religion
this is
people who only want to use a religion
to feel better than other people
and that's him and i just wish i could
look at him in the face and say how
about you do something good for the
world right now you're sitting you're
festering in your hate for other people
and you're trying to get your audience
and your followers and supporters to
believe the same thing and you're
threatening people's lives what good is
that doing for the world what good is
that doing for you for the god that you
believe in what good is that doing in
living a life of jesus
it's not
everyone understands if they read
enough of the bible while there's a lot
of stuff in there like whoa what what's
going on i can't
at least if you zero in on the jesus
stories
he was a very very giving and loving and
serving person
so how about you go out and you give and
you love and you serve
you disgusting human human being
but no you just want to stand there you
want to get the attention of people
and you want to talk about how much you
hate people for being different than you
it's so i'm so sick of having to listen
to this
and
he should be arrested right
that's a criminal level of
threatening of violence
a judge did rule luckily that uh
steadfast church will be evicted
um they're gonna be evicted for allowing
threats of violence so hooray on that
but super scary and harmful stuff
you can hear further discussions about
this topic in general i'm always getting
fired up about people going after
already marginalized groups
for absolutely no reason on my channel
if you want to watch that you can go to
luke beasley on youtube
or if you're watching this on youtube
listening the podcast there will be a
link in the description you can click to
check me out be greatly appreciated
all right everybody i have for you a
truly
bizarre clip of marjorie green and matt
gates
talking about a weird fantasy of
something or another and i just need to
apologize upfront before we look at this
some percent of you are going to
whenever you watch this you're going to
throw up
um
not really you'll be fine but it is it's
cringy so let's take a look his favorite
member
he's mine i'm on record he's at the top
for me
like
i would rather give nancy pelosi a
sponge bath than endure like one dinner
okay like like a lot of people would say
maybe pelosi is their least favorite
member no way
would you trim her i would trim her
toenails with my teeth before i would go
to dinner without him that's really
impressive
so here's how i feel now i know some of
you will watch that and be like it was
weird but why are you making a big deal
first off it's just kind of a fun story
a lot of heavy stuff lately let's laugh
at a couple goofballs but
also there is a larger important point
so first let's just go through how weird
what they were saying was for some
reason to express his hatred for adam
schiff he had to do some big long
fantasy
about
giving nancy pelosi a scrub-down bath
and then biting her toes
toenails i
i don't know why that was so specific
and
seemed kind of pre-planned
maybe something he's thought about
before but
really weird um
so that's that but then the larger
more meaningful and serious point is
this is a great example of how
right-wing politics has gotten so far
away from serious discussions about how
to address problems in our country
and i know you know that but watching
clips like that really remind you of it
marjorie green doesn't have any
committee assignments she's not working
on policies each day she has her one
vote in congress but besides that she's
not really doing much and what she is
doing is being a little media figure and
that's what we've seen a lot of these
republican politicians become it's not
about
policy it's not about implementing a
policy that will help improve the lives
of your constituents no it's about being
a media figure it's about being an
influencer she has a little mtg live
that's what it's about
and so right there he's being a little
funny guy you know saying some weird
stuff that might get his audience to
laugh
being completely
unserious and not at all trying to
address the many many issues that need
to be addressed in our country and so
while
the core reason i wanted to play that
clip is because it's just absurd
and let's just think one more time one
more time about
matt gates
saying
he would rather give nancy pelosi a
scrub down bath and
cut her toenails with his teeth
then go out to dinner with adam schiff
i don't think he's inviting you bubba
but okay
bizarre but also an indication like i
said
that they don't care it's not about it's
not serious this isn't about making
change for their constituents
they're just trying to go viral they're
trying to be provocative
trying to be the biggest name of the
republican party
tweet out stuff own the libs
that's what it's really about it's no
longer
at all policy focused and that's super
super sad
and something we need to continually
call out and we need a demand of the
politicians we like and support that
they stay focused
on the real issues
i appreciate the day of pacman show
having me fill in today it's been an
absolute pleasure i'll just plug one
more time go check me out luke beasley
on youtube we got it papa lochen over
there you can also listen to the show as
a podcast just luke beasley
anywhere you go you should be able to
find me instagram twitter all those good
things luke p beasley on twitter and i
will hopefully see you guys in the near
future